[Music]
[Music]
the girls of fifth harmony explained
that vma shade let's talk about that
moment when boom off the stage goes
number five
dinah ali lauren and normani told good
morning america's lara spencer it wasn't
so much about dissing ex-band member
camila cabello
[Music]
as it was proving they're just fine
without her we get asked all the time if
we're getting a fifth member and we
wanted to show the world in an artistic
way that hey the four of us are fifth
harmony and we're stronger and better
than we've ever been and honestly it was
such a monumental moment for us et's
katie krauss chatted with the quartet
last week they explained the
significance of their new self-titled
album does this signify a rebirth of
fifth harmony or a continuation a
rebirth
a rebirth and continuation same time and
the the really amazing thing is that we
have such an incredible bond with the
four of us
and we're definitely like sisters so
it's really such a special experience
you